c'était quand la dernière fois que vous
avez eu peur de parler en public où vous
avez eu des papillons dans le ventre
les mains moi qui ai les joues qui
chauffe parler en public
c'est la deuxième peur de l'homme juste
à trouver
alors si vous avez peur de quoi
mais si normale jusqu'en 2011
j'étais responsable de conduire jusqu'en
2011 j'ai acheté des concurrents si je
les côtoyer des centaines personnes
gérées plus crédits en cours d'autres en
revanche c'était beaucoup plus compliqué
et parfois il devenait vraiment c'est
agréable
je vous laisse imaginer à cette époque
souvent je rentrais dans l'âge et régit
tout doucement derrière gilbert
il me demandait souvent son coup et là
j'ai coupé très vite j'étais fixe
et souvent je repartais dans mon bureau
des conférences qui avait l'air
tellement bien sont contre ou bien en
fait elle était livrée avec un style oh
là je n'ai pas du tout mais pas du tout
katyn alors j'ai eu quand même quelques
belles expériences je vous rassure
et du coup j'ai décidé d'en partager
trois avec vous aujourd'hui
quoi conférence est qui m'ont appris
beaucoup de choses qui ment impactés
trois conférenciers qui se pose une
question principale chacun je suis venu
vous les donner ces questions pour que
vous puissiez aussi à partir de demain
ou peut-être même son devenir des
orateurs bien plus inspirants claire et
structurée des partis je vous emmène en
afrique du sud avec ian thomas ian il
gère une réserve animalière
il adore les lions alors ce qu'il fait
lui c'est qu'il étudie les bugs de lyon
leur fonctionnement et il transporte sa
dans des équipes
ils sont très performantes yens sa force
il raconte des histoires il lui fait
vivre
nous initions alors il plante le décor
on est avec lui dans la savane on est en
train de boire cette eau boueuse et on a
ce goût dans la bouche
on a la fraîcheur de la nuit et dans la
journée lorsqu'il nous décrit cette
savane
on a lâché à l'heure où transperce
on a eu aussi parfois les herbes les
hautes herbes de la savane
ouf deux musées
j'ai bien dit louise ou parce qu'en ce
moment
yann il se met enfin ça vaut le coup 1
il traverserait toute la scène parfois
il est à l'affut parfois confus ou alors
il bondit et là ce qu'il fait et qu'il
agit sur 55% de son enfant 55% vous
imaginez ce dont on se rappelle dans ses
conférences sont et tout cet
environnement ses histoires et ses
gestes et ça comprend 55 %
alors si vous ne le faites pas vous
laisser tout simplement la moitié de
votre un point dans les coulisses yann
ce qu'il fait aussi c'est qu'il met du
rythme et ça il le fait grâce au
dialogue entre ces entre ses gardes
hier john et martin igier noble et
parfois ils appellent sans lui ont
préféré et blake a créé des ruptures
donne et toutes ces ruptures de rythme
on est captivé que nous oreilles se
tendent utilise aussi impose aussi
important parce que ça crée une boucle
de mémoire autrement dit chaque fois qu
un conférencier dit quelque chose
d'important et qu'il fait un silence le
public mais mourir du sida
et quand on travaille sur sa voie et des
rythmes différents
on travaille juste sur 38 % de points
pour qu'on à 55% on à 38%
il reste combien y'a des matins
il restait pour sa tête
sexe et le pouvoir des mots alors il
faut bien les choisir
mais sachez que vos maux et les mots que
je prononce en ce moment bien dans vos
mémoires demain à la semaine prochaine
par contre à pau suite on est beaucoup
plus de yens la question qu'il se pose
lui qu'est ce que je veux que les gens
aussi et c'est ma première question
clément premier cadeau pour chaque fois
que vous intervenez demandez vous ce que
vous voulez que les gens ressentent et
pourquoi ça le plus simple c'est
raconter des histoires mettre des
dialogues parce que vous allez vivre des
histoires et quand les vivants du coup
mon conseil aussi et quand vous
commencez à parler vous mettez bien voix
devant votre vie vous êtes un beau geste
d'ouverture et vous y allez avec une
introduction qui va droit au but
une belle introduction ça peut être une
histoire statistiques
une anecdote une infirmation mais elle
doit aller que vous pouvez faire aussi
et ça c'est très simple vous imaginez
que vous parlez un public nous compris
dans les pas de bol ce mouvement par
contre au contraire c'est un vrai cadeau
parce que du coup ou devait forcer un
petit peu le trait devait un peu exagéré
et en exagérant un tour lent même s'ils
ont des traitements avec nous en afrique
du sud et bien on va partir en suisse
avec une femme incroyable extraordinaire
j'admire profondément carla del ponte à
l'époque lé procureur général ensuite
elle est membre de la commission anti
criminalité économique
alors je peux vous dire qu'en suisse
elle a un peu plus loin elle est invitée
par des banquiers suisses pour 82 rafale
17 pas là vous êtes tous des banquiers
suisses dfa probants il ya paul lay à
michel ce sont ses gardes du corps elle
a loué quatre chambres dans notre hôtel
c'est un bol d'or
mais deux jours heureux à lévis et elle
leur dit vous êtes responsable d'une
partie de la menace qui pèse sur moi
elle a voulu provoquer là c'est un vrai
choc émotionnel et elle avait un
objectif très populaire mon objectif
les faire collaborer vous aussi
chaque fois qu'on parle et demandez vous
ce que vous voulez que les gens font ça
c'est mon deuxième cadeau ma deuxième
inscrit ma deuxième question clé
que voulez vous que les gens passent et
autrement dit et les actions que vous
voulez déclenché moi mon action là c'est
vous ayez envie que vous utilisez alors
on va quitter la suisse vont à la
rencontre d'une femme qui s'appelle
christine malet
depuis que j'ai quitté ce travail le
responsable de congrès en est avec nous
et si je suis là aujourd'hui c'est grâce
à elle elle est tombée malade la semaine
dernière elle a dû être hospitalisée
elle m'a dit on peut pas laisser ça a
dit juan en plan puis vint alors me
voilà ici c'est une conférencière de
contenu ce qui lui importe à qui elle
parle c'est sa question à elle elle se
le demande tout le temps lorsqu'avec
cette question elle va se demander
quelles sont les attentes de son pays
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent quand vous
allez repartir ce soir avec quoi vous
voulez cantonales poche
évidemment dans ces conférences pour
avoir beaucoup d'impact elle bien on va
répondre à ces cas à ses attentes et à
ses questions alors outre la page avait
une question pour vous est-ce que vous
avez tous amenez votre cerveau ouais
longtemps d'airé je vois des hochements
donc on est parfait pour aller voir ce
que ça veut dire pas dans le cerveau on
a plusieurs façons d'appréhender
l'information et dans cette salle en ahl
aussi leur façon d'appréhender
l'informatique
il ya des gens qui vont ressentir les
choses d'autres y vont les intellectuels
une confiance et une intuition et
d'autres enfin se fier à leur logique et
donc poils bien vous posez tous une
question que ward posé quatre questions
la première est quoi ted
on a eu la réponse voilà comment ça
marche et cette journée elle est
organisée comment et à quelle heure fait
la peau métisse même pas mince qui se
promènent devant nous et les mamans je
suis
pourquoi un samedi après midi j'ai
décidé d'être là ça doit sûrement avoir
un bénéfice pour moi dans le futur donc
si vous répondez à ces quatre questions
dans vos interventions vous avez déjà
pas mal de crue mais au-delà de ça il y
à une autre méthode
j'ai vraiment un fond je vous la donne
d'abord on est dans l'émotionnel et avec
une belle intro on va créer le lien va
prendre le public trouvera aussi un
garçon dans la rue il veut aborder une
lubie glisse tout de suite il fait une
introduction il la prend dans ses bras
il a plus de chances des peuples c'est
pareil quand on connaît une belle intro
je vous rappelle une histoire une
anecdote une citation une affirmation
très pop qui va soit vous bouleverser
émotionnellement soit vous choquer
ensuite on part dans concret donc il ya
un plan et une promesse mon plan à moins
ces trois histoires trois conventions la
promesse donnée trois cantons ou que
vous aussi puissiez au plus inspirants
plus clair et plus que tout ensuite il
ya des explications
c'est exactement ce que je suis en train
de faire maintenant j'explique démons
contenu mais chaque fois qu'on extrait
il faut illustré ils ont onze morts ou
en andorre son public en tout cas et
après on entend des conférences et
qu'ils vont dire le public
une fois qu'on a expliquées et
illustrées et bien c'est très simple une
très belle façon avec une conclusion qui
sera aussi fort
l'introduction là on a couvert toutes
les sommes dues et alexin vous dire que
vous êtes vos interventions seront
nettement meilleure alors je vais vous
proposer une illustration métaphorique
de ce que je viens de vous dire
c'est un sandwich une tranche de pain
est solide
l'intro où va se baser dessus c'est si
vous n'êtes pas bon dans l'intro où l'on
prend son téléphone et regarder ensuite
s'il y a le plan est la promesse il ya
le contenu d'un booster
après il ya des belles tomates pour les
illustrations et puis évidemment en
conclusion un autre point pour qu'on
puisse bien manger non ça va tout
s'écroule et une prise de parole
raisonnable
deux messages clés concourant mettre un
terme à ces lundi lescure et le problème
c'est que c'est souvent comme ça on
écoute des gens parler ils sont
tellement généreux ils vous donnent
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
vu dans la salle vous vous dites est ce
que je prends ce que je mange en faisant
un peu de thym une finale que gérer
morlaix la question qu'elle se pose
qu'est ce que je voulais et c'est ma
troisième question mais ce que je veux
que les gens routier j'ai vu donner
encore une méthode
moi je suis madame ne peut d'aller
prendre une feuille blanche
vous allez écrire qu il fasse faire la
tête en répondant à la question qu'est
ce que je veux tout de suite vous allez
hiérarchiser souvent dans la majorité
des cas le point numéro un n'est jamais
le bon on y va descendre dans le
classement
et puis le rêve va remonter il a et bien
vous allez prendre les 1 2 et 3 1 2 3
garder sain et le reste d'accès pourront
tour et pour une autre intervention mais
c'est pas pour aujourd'hui
si vous faites ça deviendrait bien plus
performant ces conférenciers visons un
grand point commun
évidemment il accorde autant
d'importance
victor hugo qui disait déjà en forme le
fond qui remonte à la surface
on doit tous un court où beaucoup
d'importance aux îles emosson magnifique
mais qui sont figés par une posture
prêts privés
parfois on va partir d'aujourd'hui dans
concours de demain pensez à ces trois
questions
les gens m'ont accordée aux coûts
encourus et bing devient fait des
conférences et si c'est pas des
conférences et ce sera au moins des
ovins qui inspire en clair pour bien
vous le compreniez s'ingénie au point
une prudence c'est près de ma surprise
pour la conclusion vous rappellons la
conclusion marquante est frappant je
vais vous montrer levé vers la musique
on va tous dans son ensemble de prêts
les prêts ok merci alors la chorégraphie
est très très simple qu'est ce que je
veux qu'il ressente
qu'est ce que je veux qu'ils retiennent